okay
let's start um welcome to the ddps
seminar today before we introduce
today's speaker let's go over some rules
and logistics uh first of all
please mute yourself during the talk
unless you have questions
so that our speaker can talk without
unnecessary interruption
if you have um clear clarification
questions you are welcome to mute
yourself and ask those questions
otherwise please you use chat room to
post your questions so that we can
address them in
q a session at the end second no
classified
discussion is allowed here so watch out
finally the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in
our youtube channel all right that's
about it
now let me introduce our speaker today
uh it is an
honor to host today's speaker professor
to
dress who is an associate professor of
aerospace engineering and the director
of the center
for data-driven computational physics at
the university of
michigan ann arbor he holds a phd in
aerospace engineering and a
master's degree in applied mathematics
from the university of maryland his
research interests
are in various aspects of computational
modeling including data driven
and video studio modeling status
statistical inference
numerical methods and physics based
modeling
he is also a founder and chief scientist
of the silicon valley based
startup which is geminus
ai which is focused on developing
digital twins
for industrial processes today
professor durasami will present tours
robots accurate and tractable reduced
auto models for multi-scale
multi-physics problems which is aligned
with our
core interest here at our lab so we
expect a great talk today
now without further ado let me post pass
the button to
uh karthik here you go it's all yours
thank you yang su thank you for the
introduction and for the opportunity to
uh you know talk about uh release adam
modeling with you today
so before i get started let me
acknowledge uh
my so co-authors so to speak um in fact
these guys did almost all of the work so
chiang wang who is a
research scientist in my group and two
pesticide
and david zoo and i also want to
acknowledge that
what i'm going to be talking about today
is part of a center of excellence that
is funded by the air force
and so it's a four university project
um so along with units of michigan we
have university of texas at austin
perdue university and nyu
all right so reduce our models i mean
people are becoming more familiar with
it as days go by
uh generally speaking uh the the words
reduce
order modeling uh what i mean by them
is taking a certain set of governing
equations
and then developing mathematically
formal reduced order models
to try to solve the same equations but
on some lower dimensional manifold
okay and this idea is not new
uh it's been around for quite a while
and
if you actually see um the usage of
reduced auto models
in many fields um we have production
ready
uh software here i'm showing
a software by the name of from the
company called
axelos so they
take very very complex systems at least
in terms of
geometry like a ship
and they built these component-based
reduced order models
and then uh in very very quick time
you can build these models and you can
execute them almost in real time right
so that's like the dream
but if you look at where
roms have been most successful so far
it's mostly been in linear problems
mildly non-linear problems elliptic
problems and highly viscous problems
of course there's a lot of research
happening in more complex physics
but in terms of production ready
software
this field is still restricted to these
kind of regimes
and so what we want to do is
extend these types of reducer models
for use in extremely complex multi-scale
multiphysics problems
uh as one example here um i'm showing
uh a rocket combustor right so what is
shown on the right
in this figure is is a rocket engine
and uh if you take if you zoom
in close to the injector flow field and
you zoom in you see that
the flow field is quite complex because
you know you have
oxidizer coming in here fuel fuel coming
in here
there is mixing happening there is very
small scales
but then because of the confinement you
have acoustics
uh so you have multiphysics processes
and multiscale phenomena so even if you
want to simulate the flow field around
one injector
it takes about a million cpu hours
now if you want to do a real engine the
problem is there are hundreds of such
injectors right so this is probably
going to take the largest computer in
the world right now and then
it's going to be running for a long time
even in some of the most powerful
machines right so
practically full-scale computations for
something as complex as rocket engine is
not even feasible
and even if it's feasible to do design
studies
it's pretty much intractable right so we
want to build roms of
problems that are as complex as what i'm
showing here
so let me take a few minutes to
introduce to you
um the basic setting in which we develop
reduced data models
so so let's say we start with
the reacting navier-stokes equations
which govern
flows like this okay and then
let's say we you we have spatially
discretized equations we have the
continuous full outer model
so this would be a high dimensional set
of ordinary differential equations
where the number of degrees of freedom
for even
one injector here could be order of the
order of 100 million
so it's a very large dynamical system
all right
so when we solve the full order model
typically
we use some kind of a time integration
scheme so this is the discrete full auto
model
so the most basic thing one would do in
reduced data models
is to do a linear decomposition
so you have a linear set of basis
functions you have a set of basis
coefficients
and then you have some scaling and then
you have a reference state
but the key thing here is the number of
unknowns
reduces from this n to k
okay so you're just solving for the
basis coefficients instead of the full
set of degrees of freedom and while
capital n could be of the order of
hundred million
k could be of the order of hundred or
thousand which is what we're going to be
seeing today
and once you have defined a manifold or
a subspace
in which you want to work with
then there are various options in which
by which you can
project either the continuous full order
model or the discrete full auto model
to the subspace if you use the galerkin
projection which is the most commonly
used
uh projection technique where the test
uh space is the same as the trial space
then you get this kind of uh
uh equation uh reduced model equation
but rather um if you
while garcin techniques work very well
for elliptic problems and even for
hyperbolic problems in in certain
regimes
for many problems stability
is is a major issue so we tend to use
petroglyphing techniques and
petroglyphic techniques
uh come in various forms and one such
vector of gulking technique that we will
follow a lot uh is the least choice
projection
so effectively you're taking the
discrete residual and then
you are introducing your trial space and
then you're trying to minimize
the least choir uh residual
so this will result in a petroclean
wrong
so
so so what i want to say is the most
basic
uh galler kinron has
some appealing properties in the
continuous setting um
the the least squares or the petroglyph
in roms have some
properties that are favorable in the
discrete setting
but fundamentally uh the one of the main
reasons we want to
pursue these petroglyphs and runs is
that galakin drums can be unstable
so um we have uh
this paper on the archive where you can
find um
this the following proof so this is
somewhat uh
illustrative for the kind of things
we're going to see
so again let's now restrict the problem
to be linear
right so you have a linear continuous
full auto model
if you maybe discretize it using a
backward euler
in time you get a discrete full auto
model
and then if you do a least quest
projection
we can actually prove that if the
discrete full odd model
is asymptotically stable in this sense
then the associated least squares based
rom
is also asymptotically stable with no
further assumptions required
okay so um if you're from the finite
element community they should not be
surprising
but i would still maybe uh encourage you
to look at the proof here because we've
gone through a linear algebra
end-to-end linear algebra proof rather
than a functional analytic proof so
basically this establishes the property
that
lee squares runs help stability it's not
a
new idea as i said pilot element people
have been doing it for a long time
one other interesting proof in the same
paper
is that we show that um even when you
use
a galerkin uh discretization or or
regulation sort of model
you can show that the resulting radius
on the model
is conditionally stable okay so it is
not as if
even if you have very strong multiscale
multiphysics phenomena
it is not necessary that the gelatin rom
is always stable
always unstable there are certain
conditions by which
under which this can be stable and one
of them of course is if you have a
symmetric problem
but even if you don't have a symmetric
problem uh
even pure hyperbolic equations you can
actually get the necessary stability
okay so
so the reason why i spent some time
introducing these to you is this is the
most
uh commonly used radius r models and
i just wanted to anchor the presentation
there
however all of that said when we take
either
the galaxy rom or the least squares
galactic iran
and we applied the problems as complex
as the one that i showed earlier
they immediately break okay so the
gulkin doesn't even get off
the first few time steps and the at
least squires petroglyn ram also blows
up
fairly quickly and the reason is many
and i don't want to say that all of the
developments i'm showing
is for combustion problems but
much of the development has been
motivated by combustion problems
so these are equally applicable to other
problems like hypersonics plasmas etc
but if you take combustion as an example
as i said earlier
there are many different interactions
that happen at many different scales
the reaction regions are extremely
intense if you look
at the numbers here these are extremely
large
but then they may be spread over one or
two cells they may
be under resolved and
the other main problem that
roms face when we apply them to these
types of problems is that
when something small changes at the
inlet the flow topology can drastically
change
and later in the talk i'll actually show
you what we do to address these types of
problems
okay so um
high level these are the three things uh
that uh you know you
i want you to take away okay first i
already spoke about
many of the challenges uh the flow
physics
itself brings right like extreme
stiffness distributed
flame fronts uh multi-scale nature so in
the first part of the talk i'll focus on
how to keep these kinds of rom stable
and accurate
okay the second part of the talk i'm
actually going to show how we can be
adaptive right so
i mentioned that if you change something
in the inlet
the entire float topology changes so how
do roms handle that
but even more so uh even more
challenging than that
so what i'm showing here is the
pod uh purple orthogonal decomposition
of a 2d shear layer okay and
so basically if i use say
0.167 milliseconds of training data i
don't remember how many snapshots it was
and then i do an svd
this is how the spectrum decays okay
then i use some more this is how the
spectrum decays
okay so i use more data this is how the
so basically when you get into a chaotic
flow situation
you cannot handle the the amount of
information
in a very efficient way if you are
sticking to a
static set of bases whether you're a
linear manifold or a non-linear manifold
it becomes
very hard and the third thing i'm going
to talk about today
is the fact that when i started my
presentation
i mentioned that you can't even do one
full order model for the system but then
we want to build
a reduced order model for that system
and the way we do that
is by breaking up the domain into
component roms
and then combine those component roms
with the full order model
so that the full system simulations are
possible okay
so i'll go into this in more detail in
each of the three parts of the talk
but here is how it's spelt out right
first part is on robustness and accuracy
basically this part the second part of
the talk is
adaptivity how to handle things like
chaotic flows and
big parameter changes and the third part
of the talk
is on tractability meaning how do we
enable
simulations of complex systems where you
can't even afford one
full auto model okay so that's the plan
of action today
and after each part i will give a brief
pause so if you have any questions you
can ask so that
it doesn't become one uh 45 minute or 50
minute talk that
be too boring all right so let's focus
on the first part
and as i said almost all of what i'm
going to talk about
in the first part is in this paper i'll
also reference the end of the paper
so um so i mentioned to you that
um petroglycan basis
or a petroglycan projection is
beneficial
but at the same time there are some
additional things that we have to do
okay and the ideas for
this approach come from various
different viewpoints so the inspirations
come from various different viewpoints
and i cover all of them in the paper
that i
i just referenced i'll just walk you
through
what we do okay so let's say we start
with the discretized
full order model equations i'm using
backward euler as an example
so the first thing we do is we
do a variable transformation okay from
the original set of variables q to
another set of variables
s and s should also be complete okay and
and the many reasons why we do this
variable transformation
um it is for stability purposes it is
for
convenience purposes for instance in in
combustion problems
even though we want to solve the
governing equations in conservation
conservative variables um we can
transform them to primitive variables
but still retain
the conservation properties and the way
we maintain
conservation is by introducing
these um transform variables
in a dual time stepping setting right so
now
um this this capita this this n
represents physical
time steps and p represents pseudo time
steps
okay so we're still solving the
equations in conservation form
but then the unknowns now become the
uh transform set of variables s
and now in serial time i can do a
linearization
and i can write the fully discrete
residual in serial time
and as long as i am driving this
residual to zero
i will be solving in the s variables but
i'll still be conservative
okay so we still haven't done any
reduced order model
and we started modeling yet but this is
just the transformation step
okay so this is where we were in the
last slide and then we can do a
decomposition
so this decomposition can be to a linear
manifold or to a non-linear manifold as
as youngsu does i'll mostly talk about
the linear manifold maybe i'll show one
slide on the non-linear
so then we do a decomposition just like
i showed earlier
we built a reconstruction of
the transformed variables in terms of
a linear basis in this slide and basis
coefficients and
additional scaling matrix and then
before we do
a least squares projection we introduce
another level of scaling
okay so after we do that
uh scaling and then we do a little bit
of algebra
you would finally get a radius out of
model that looks like this
in the pseudo time okay so again these
sr
are the basis coefficients that we are
solving for p
represents the zero time sub iterations
and w represents your
uh effective petroleum basis petroglycan
test basis so um
so basically we did a bunch of things so
what do we get
so first we get discrete consistency at
the sub iteration level
second even though the system is not the
full auto model is not symmetric
the reduced order model is symmetrized
and so it inherits the stability
properties that i
talked about earlier and at the same
time we are not losing conservation
we also in the paper if you look at it
we also add some local stability
promoting techniques
and we also show that you can extend it
to explicit schemes as well
okay so these are some desirable
properties um
so that's the for
that's the reduced order model but as
anyone who does
uh non-linear reduce other models knows
this by itself does not reduce to does
not result in a
significant cost reduction so to achieve
more uh significant cost reduction you
have to do what is called as hyper
reduction
which is ensuring that the residual is
only evaluated
at a few points and
so we introduced an additional set of
bases to represent the residual
and do an interpolation but end of the
day
we go from reducing the complexity
computational complexity from order n
which was
let's say 100 million to order of the
number of samples which tends to be
about you know a few thousand in our
problems
so again i'm skipping some details here
but
if you look at this paper we go into
some additional details on how exactly
to do this hyper-reduction
carefully and in in a scalable fashion
so there are some multiple there are a
few different ways in which you have to
do sampling
um we initially start with uh qr
pivoting to find out what the best
samples are but
when you are in a really complex
multi-scale setting
and you have say 100 basis functions
100 sample points won't cut it right we
need a lot more
so in addition to what the qr
gives um we do some additional
oversampling
okay so so in this paper uh
chris goes into a lot of detail on how
to do that efficiently
and some of the results that you would
see in the paper is for
um you know this test combustor which
has about 15 million degrees of freedom
you can actually get about four orders
of magnetic reduction in computational
time
for reasonably for reasonably low errors
um and one more interesting thing that
we show here is
so if you do not use any hyper reduction
you get a speed up of
10 compared to the full order model at a
certain level of error
but if you do the over sampling
carefully and the hyper reduction
carefully
you can maintain the almost the same
error as the
unsampled rom and be much faster
okay and again very quickly
walking you through a tour of the
results so again
we are doing we're demonstrating this
technique
on this this rocket injector rocket
injector configuration
um you know if so as i said this work is
part of
part of the center of excellence and
when we started about two years ago we
would never be able to run
a calculation like this um with any
level of robustness
um but now um
you know with this additional robustness
that i robustness
improving techniques that i just spoke
about
we can do a good reconstruction we can
do a reasonable
future state prediction we can keep the
error low
and in fact so this is the full order
model snapshot of the temperature
um you can get stable solutions at 20
mode 60 modes in fact we can go in up to
seven or eight modes or even four modes
it won't be as accurate but still
robustness is there
okay so
yeah overall as i mentioned we can get
about three to four orders of magnitude
in cost reduction
maintain reasonable level very good
accuracy during the reconstruction stage
we obviously lose some accuracy in the
in the in the prediction stage
but it is possible to do these reduced
models
and a lot of this has been done in as
part of a scalable interface
so even if we have a separate different
cfd solver
or a multiphysic solver a lot of what
we've done
can actually be leveraged but of course
there has to be some level of
interaction with the solver
okay so all of that was good news but so
what do we have to improve uh if we zoom
into the results
and this is also something that all of
us in the reduced
model community have to come out and be
more self-critical of our work
you know inside the training interval
everything
works reasonably well so i have three
curves here
so the black line is the absolute best
the roms can do because
this actually represents projection
error
and then the the blue and the red is the
wrong with them without sampling
so things are quite okay in the
training stage so i mean visually you
you don't see much of a difference
in fact even in the prediction stage
visually you may not see much of a
difference but when you examine the
errors
you can clearly see that the error jumps
when you are doing
your when you're doing true future state
prediction
and for certain quantities the error
jumps more so than the others
and if you see there is nothing that the
projection
nothing that the uh
petrol king can do because the
projection error itself is is high
okay so um this is one of the
limitations of linear manifolds so one
thing that you can do
you know this is something that young
zoo also works on
is to replace the linear basis
representation with a non-linear basis
representation so now again you have
you're solving for this latent space
variables sr it is still of dimension k
but instead of a linear basis you go to
a non-linear manifold
you can apply the same procedure that i
just spoke about
and you can still get a symmetrized rom
that inherits many of the properties
that i
spoke about earlier okay so
i just had a science talk where i went
into some results but i just wanted to
say that
you know what i just presented
is applicable not just to linear
problems
linear manifolds but also nonlinear
manifolds
and nonlinear manifolds do certainly
help
reduce the error in
the future state predictions and
parametric predictions
but i think one ongoing area of research
is
how to efficiently do hyper reduction
right so
i walked you through i at least hinted
that hyper reduction is critical
and
for linear for linear manifold roms
hyper reduction and sparse sampling is
very well developed
but for non-linear manifolds it is not
and it continues to be
a research area right now
okay so i'll just show this one slide
and then
see if anyone has questions but
the reason why i want to show this slide
is i just wanted to place this work in
the context of other things that we're
doing
so in our center we are
of course calling the the static pod
with dime with
lee squires and gherkin petroglyn as the
baseline reducer models and to that
to the baseline roms we are adding a lot
more features and what i just spoke
about
is in this green box and i just hinted
about this other green box
but there's a lot of other work going on
and the rest of the presentation i'm
going to talk about
how we can get much better accuracy
and how we can enable those
intractable problems but i'll stop here
and see if there are some questions uh
that anyone has in the first part of the
talk
i'll be happy to take them and then move
on to the second part
um actually there's a two questions from
mark miller
in chat room the first question is
for any given full load of model can you
create a
progression of roms of decreasing
fidelity and then
use solutions on smaller roms to prime
the solution
on the next bigger one and continue this
all the way back up to significantly
accelerate the flow of model
yes i think that's uh you know like a
multi-scale coarse graining idea
the answer is yes except i don't
understand what you mean by priming
um if priming means preconditioning or
providing an initial guess then
absolutely i think it can be done in
fact
at the same conference i saw a paper
from nathan kutz's group
where they were doing non-intrusive roms
but
yeah they were going scale by scale yeah
it's certainly possible
and next question is are reduced to the
models being considered
and or would they be useful for purpose
of populating data set for machine
learning
or ass yes certainly i mean
certainly as a surrogate to populate the
data space suddenly being used
all right so uh let me move on to the
second part which is
so as i mentioned the motivation for the
second part comes
here right so uh when you're in problems
with strong convection
and chaoticity um
linear manifolds break down and even
nonlinear manifolds cannot handle
parametric changes so how can we
get past that okay so
again it starts with a question i mean
we can always show these nice results
using reduced order models but there's
always this nagging question
are they truly predictive or have we
just done a glorified interpolation
okay glorified interpolation
is also useful i don't want to downplay
it but for many problems we actually
want the roms to be predictive right so
that's why we need to move past
static spaces and i already mentioned
this
even if you have a linear conv linear
advection of a pulse like this
and you do a linear basis
you'll see that you would need to keep
almost all of the basis functions
right so it's it's not it's not very
efficient
and of course parametric roms when when
when
the parameters change and you stick to
static uh basis whether it's linear or
non-linear you get into
you may need too much data okay
so our solution is to use adaptive
spaces the same kind of
setting similar type of setting that i
showed earlier except now
the test basis and the trial basis will
change in time
and it would basically follow the
solution manifold okay
so it's basically doing a local low rank
structure and time
and you know we work on uh local
residuals in space
and as i'll show you this is very
naturally suited for parametric roms but
one of the big advantages if we have
good adaptive roms you
actually can start with very little data
and we'll show you what veritable data
means
okay so again this is generally the idea
so if you have a 3d space and you want
to go to a line
if your static basis is the best you can
do but then if you use adaptive basis
you can build a local linear space
around each of these points
so this is the petroglyn rom that i
showed earlier
um the v is your test trial basis w is
your test basis
now the idea of adaptive rom is to
change the basis functions as the
solution manifold evolves
and we i'm going to more or less follow
um this paper that i've
shown here it's it's i'm journaling
trying to be computing from last year
we have some new things but that's
a detail that i want to get into i don't
want to get into
so effectively what we do here
is that every time step or every few
time steps
we take the old basis and then we do a
rank one update
and that rank one update comes from a
solution of a problem like this which
basically
depends on the system residual okay
that's a high level picture
and so let's see what this buys us
okay so here i have a problem that looks
like it's simple but
in the online setting it's very hard so
you have a moving laminar flame
okay so first of all the motion itself
is a
challenge but second if you run it
online there has to be a lot of the
things that the rom has to get correctly
otherwise it's going to blow up
okay so
if i just use very little data okay so
the rom starts when the flame is here
and then for the adaptive basis i get
data from here to here
and then i start running the rom
um in truly predictive mode and then if
i am
doing the static basis i'm going to take
a lot of data
okay um so
so that's step one right so i'm
comparing it 20 more
rom based on adaptive basis to 120 more
rom based on a static basis and
turns out that the 20 mode wrong with
adaptive basis
can be truly predictive whereas the uh
the static basis rom is only
good in the reconstruction phase and
immediately falls apart
okay uh and that we kind of knew and it
should not be
surprising but the real thing that we
want to examine here
is are these roms truly predictive okay
so here is how we quantify productivity
so i take the rom that i shown
shown in the previous in this slide
so this is the training data when the
flame starts here and the flame
moves until here that's my training data
for the adaptive basis rom
and there are no external perturbations
here okay
now i want to take that ready starter
model and now i'm
applying it in a problem where i
introduce strong downstream
perturbations okay
but i'm forcing the flame at 100
kilohertz
at some five percent amplitude and we
can still
see that the the adaptive base is rom
not only stays stable but it can
actually predict what is going on in
tree
okay whereas the uh the blue is the
static basis from it completely falls
apart because
it has not seen any of this before of
course the adaptive basis struggles a
bit towards the end of the domain but
um again for different forcing
frequencies
it does work well right so this is one
measure of of predictivity
a slightly harder test case so here we
have a non-reacting mixing layer
your your stream comes your streams come
at different
speeds and the this
mixing layer forms and the flow actually
turns chaotic we put a probe and you
look at the velocity
look at the pressure this is how it
looks like it's not repeatable
and this is the picture i showed earlier
if you
use a static basis static linear basis
and even if you cover one acoustic cycle
this is how the
singular values look like you get more
data
it just expands right so more data is
not going to solve this problem
right so when you choose static basis
you are
you immediately like set yourselves up
for failure
and again the the adaptive basis works
quite well here
so again um uh
even if we use the static basis that is
trained
from here to here okay so this is the
training period for the
adaptive basis and
the rest of the prediction
the rest of the time the adaptive basis
rom is in true prediction mode
whereas the static basis rom fails so
again one other additional thing
and now we are doing parametric
prediction we are changing the
velocities and
still evaluating whether um the
adaptive basis rom can do the job and it
can okay so
so everything seems to work very well
there are a lot more tests here
i don't want to belabor the point um we
can of course break the adaptive basis
at when we add some really crazy amount
of perturbations but
by and large it's very robust and works
very well
and in the interest of time i will skip
this example
it also works for this this combustion
problem
but the point i want to make here is not
that
adaptive basis is the solution to
everything
but rather that the adaptive basis works
extremely well
and it can be predictive but then there
are still some
um open research items here
you know in the first part of the
presentation i was bragging a lot about
how efficient my roms were
the adaptive basis roms are not as
efficient it's still an
ongoing area of research and the reason
why it's not efficient is not because of
the updates that we make
it's because it is hard to get a good
set of sampling points the hyper
reduction step is
all is a little more complicated so
that's a research area for us
um um okay so that's the
second part i kind of went through that
quickly
because i wanted to save time for the
last part and also
have a discussion at the end but i want
to quickly ask if there are questions
on the adaptive basis part again i went
through that quickly but
the details are in the paper and
the key idea is we basically make a rank
one update to the
test and trial basis
and that update is based on evaluation
of the residual
is that a quick question i can take
all right if not let's move to the last
part right so remember
again reminding you the last part is can
we enable ready sort of models of
systems that are not tractable
okay of the full order model
and here we are breaking this
typical paradigm of roms where
we have a full order model of a system
and then we have some data from that
system and we want to create a
parametric rom
okay so we are scratching that and we
are saying okay
what we want to do is we want to create
roms of a class of systems where
the full order model is not available at
the system level okay
for example we want to do
systems like this okay so
let's say i have an engine like this so
i have many injectors
where all this complicated reactions
happen and then i have a region where
i'm dominated by the acoustics can i
simulate can i build
a reduced data model by training these
component roms okay so i'm going to take
one part of the domain
it's somewhat repeatable
and then i want to force that truncated
domain ready sort of
truncated domain uh when you when it's
being trained
i want to force it via many different
frequencies and i want to add so many
pertinations
such that i can recreate some of the
conditions that the
rom would see when it's integrated as
part of the full system okay
so first we start with training a
component rom and once that rom is
trained i want to assemble those ready
starter models together
and say okay can i uh use that
ready starter model to examine
the dynamics of this engine this engine
and this engine
okay so there are more injectors in each
engine
and then sometimes the combustion
chamber shape
can change okay and i can still use it
again the reason why we use reduced
models here is this is the physics
intensive part this is where 98
or 99 percent of the computational cost
goes
and this is the geometrically changing
part right so the
we can still do a full outer model here
because the physics is
basically long wavelength acoustics
whereas here there is a lot more
complicated things and then of course we
can also do parametric things
so the key idea is to train these roms
in the truncated domain setting and then
assemble them together
so i want to show this in a 1d example
to tell you why this is important and
how we are doing it
maybe i'll start from the beginning so
here is a
one-dimensional combustor
now because of the way uh rocket
combustion
works if the length of the
combustion chamber is small
is how the solution evolves okay so this
is pressure at some point
sorry this is pressure in the entire
domain
uh changing in time and this is
basically the pressure at one point
okay so what this figure shows is when
the combustion chamber is long
the flow becomes unstable but when the
combustion chamber is small
the flow is stable okay so now i want to
be able to build a reducer
model that is applicable to both
combustors or
even combustors of any arbitrary length
okay so that's the challenge that i have
so what we end up doing is
i want to isolate the part of the domain
that is common to all the combustors
which is
say the the front part of the or the
injection region
okay so i want to isolate that part
and then i want to build a reduced order
model
of just that part and when building the
reduce data model of that part
i want to give it all kinds of forcing
so that when it's actually integrated as
part of a
system the ron will have seen the kind
of things it expects to see
okay so that's the idea so we isolate
the domain
build a full ladder model and then we
force the full order model in many
different ways
and then we build a reduced order model
of
this truncated domain and then
we couple it with the full order model
okay so y
are some kind of a flux interface okay
so even though this example is
somewhat simplistic the message here is
this part is the physics intensive part
and
this part is the part where the geometry
changes
so i have obtained a reduction of the
physics intensive part
and i'm going to be changing the the the
geometry in the other part
this part takes a much less time to
compute than this okay so that's
that's the multi-fidelity aspect here
and uh again so that is
this paper um david's paper
in awa journal where we go through this
and we actually show that by just
training the truncated domain
we can actually get the dynamics of many
different
combustors um of course you need to be
forcing the truncated domain draw a full
auto model at
a certain level of frequencies but
once you do that we can actually build
ready startup models for the full system
and we can we are basically almost free
of the geometry right so
however long the combustion chamber
length is
um the fact that i trained the full auto
model in a certain way
helps and
we did the same kind of verification in
a more complicated case but
the message is the same we would just
basically train
these individual injected domains and
then force them in the training
and then we stitch them together to
create a reduced order model of a system
but the roms were basically based on
these mode like these unit problems
all right so um
i just wanted to keep to keep the time
but
again i'll summarize the three three
main
parts of the talk right so the three
questions
that i addressed first i said um
you know we want to build roms for
problems that are
very complex so we want to address the
stiffness non-linearity and multi-scale
nature
okay for that i presented
this
transformation to secondary variables i
scaled i added a dual time step i scaled
again
and then i used the least squares that
led to these discretely discretely
symmetrized
structure preserving roms second i said
static and linear manifolds
are not very useful if we want to do
true predictions
and for that we can use adaptive basis
and non-linear manifolds i specifically
covered adaptive basis
and the way it helps is it breaks the
so-called kolmogorov end with
and the local low rank projections are
very useful
and then the third part was can we do
roms of systems for which
the full order model is unaffordable and
for that i said okay
we can take these truncated domains
train them with various levels of
forcing and then we can integrate them
together to get the full system
prediction going okay so those are the
three parts i covered
if you ask me what are the most
important uh research
areas as far as projection based roms go
i already mentioned this uh sampling
right so the hyper reduction
for adaptive and non-linear manifolds is
incredibly uh
important and the second part which i
didn't talk about but
we have a lot of work going on in our
center and other people are also working
on it is
um this question of intrusive is
non-intrusive right so everything i
spoke about today is an intrusive wrong
which means i take the system of
equations and i
retain that system and then i i work
with that system of equations
but there are other approaches where
people are
being purely data-driven of course
data-driven means
you need more data but you actually
inherit less of these
stability and stiffness issues if you do
that
and of course there is a hybrid you can
use inclusive and non-intrusive
combinations of them mixing and matching
so these are some of the areas that i
think
require a lot more research and
this is my last slide i'll just say that
i spoke about
three separate aspects of what we're
doing in the center but
you can visit our website and check out
a lot more that we're doing
okay but then i'll stop talking and uh
take questions
well thank you so much for the great
talk um
karthik um it was super interesting
uh at least to me i think it's super
interesting
to many people here also um so we do
have
questions um the first question is i can
see the questions so
i can say for the time of reading and
comment right
so the question from fadi on comment on
enforcing conservation laws
for these adaptive roms very good
question um
so there is uh some good work coming out
of uh collaboration between kevin
kahlberg and the group and notre dame
about
enforcing conservation and stiffness and
other
other properties for static basis roms
and maybe even for
for linear and non-linear but we have
not enforced
conservation in the adaptive realms
especially when we use sampling so
that's
perhaps an area that i in fact that's a
good point i would probably add
uh imposition of additional properties
as
a as a research area i should have
mentioned that as well
yeah so we have not done it for adaptive
roms but we do it for static roms
and the second question is uh a bit
about non-intrusive roms
so we are pursuing two classes of
non-intrusive roms
one um which is led by um
professor karen wilcox's group um out of
uh
texas austin so they look at the liv
what they call as a lift and learn
approach where they take
our set of variables they argument them
and then this is called a lifting
transformation
and then they prescribe the structure of
the rom to be quadratic
so that's one approach the other
approach that we
um pursue in in our group again you can
find some of the publications in this
page
is we directly use convolutional
autoencoders we
the special thing we do is we do
convolutional encoders in space
as well as in time and then in the
in the space-time reduced latent space
we
we apply regressors so those are two
approaches that we pursue we also have a
cookman-based approach
but you can find all the papers here
and then the next question from harley
is is the raw model optimized for
particular observables
uh good question now one paper in our 33
or 34 that we have in the center
we're looking at goal oriented runs but
generally everything that i showed today
we're going for full state
but yes focusing on specific observables
would certainly be
a good direction to work in and i would
say that's one of the strengths of
non-intrusive roms
because non-intrusive roms are so
flexible right you can pretty much
throw anything at it you can throw any
set of variables
you can go after anything you want
you're not bound by completeness and
conservation doesn't mean anything so in
a sense they are maybe too flexible but
i think goal oriented roms
i would say non-intrusive methods may be
better suited but there are also people
who are working on goal-oriented
intrusive roms but yeah so far
we've just worked on full state and
we're not optimizing for any specific
observable
thank you thank you so much for the
answers
um is there any other questions from
audience
now i do have a question for the um
you know the third topics you
presented um very quickly but yes
go ahead in order to uh train the
so-called component rom yeah right uh
you apply some boundary conditions okay
the the second
from the top yeah what what sort of
boundary concern
i think it's kind of crucial exactly
those quality of boundary conditions you
apply yeah i i glossed over it but
um they have to be kind of relevant
to the flow that you're looking at okay
so in these problems
um you know these are
yeah these are the full auto models so
basically the
the driving physics here at the
interface
is an acoustic wave okay
so in this case the only input that we
gave was
a signal with a bunch of sinusoidal
frequencies
okay i don't think i showed it but
yeah so we basically chose a range of
frequencies and we just input a
sinusoidal wave
and that was enough
but of course when we go to a problem
like this there is a lot more
right so here we did a little bit of
cheating
because we said okay even though we are
training this individual roms
we're actually giving it the conditions
that it
is expected to see um but yeah
in a more general case um
you have to be somewhat careful about
how you force it so our approach is
let's say you have 100 injectors right
you can just take
say four or five injectors put them
together
and then you can put up them a long wave
and short wave
but but generally you're right
especially if we are not using adaptive
roms
how you train the truncated domain roms
becomes
very critical right back to roms are
less
prone to less sensitive to the training
right i mean i'm sure you're probably
familiar with the
um antonio patera's uh you know
yeah the component we do still model for
linear problems
exactly that's the very first slide that
i showed it's actually from his company
yeah exactly and there they use
they use pairwise training so you you
use
two different components attach them
together and apply
some boundary condition in the ports and
um collect the snapshots at the bottom
you know the interface yeah and
that sort of methodology
can be applicable to your problem
methodology
also yes yeah i think tony patera and a
few others
especially there are things called these
port hamiltonian roms and a few others
yeah so they're able to do things very
rigorously
and uh it's excellent work and we can
get a lot of inspiration from that
type of work but it's not directly
applicable because our problem
these problems are non-linear yeah
non-linearity is probably okay but
multi-scale and transport makes it much
harder but
absolutely there are there is
inspiration we can get from those
approaches
and in in science csc there were
quite a few talks along the lines of
what he just mentioned
awesome um i guess uh this
davis sue the paper ai double a
yeah is talking about that okay awesome
yeah
yeah away we just have the 1d example
this picture is actually from that paper
on and all of the 1d results are from
that
paper so i would encourage you to take a
look it was actually even predictive
even for frequencies that we did not
include in the forcing it was still
able to do a reasonable job but of
course it's a simple problem
and simple physics because it's 1d but
yeah the goal is to be able to do these
things reliably for
you know really complex problems right
right
yeah yeah that's what we all aiming to
achieve okay uh any other questions
from audience
yeah thanks for um yeah
sticking around i know it's i went
through the last
one and a half parts fairly quickly but
i wanted to give you the high level
picture and motivations and
what we're doing and you will find a lot
more details
in in the papers that i pointed out and
i'm always
happy to pursue a conversation over zoom
or email
or whatever um mode of communication
you're interested in
exactly so i mean this is like the like
the starting point and
exactly the people who listen to your
presentations
definitely can directly contact you
and ask questions and even
you know if we can do the future
collaboration
together that would be wonderful and
perfect
okay if there's no other uh questions we
will
wrap up let's thank our speaker
kathy for the wonderful talk and it was
very
informal and yeah and i i think it's
it's very exciting topic he has
presented today
thank you thank you thank you very much
all for for listening and young sue for
your uh
invitation no problem thank you so much
for
accepting the invitation thank you very
much okay
thank you bye bye